Nous lisons en moyenne 200 mots à la minute.
Anna Jones a lu Harry Potter au rythme de 4000 mots à la minute,
avec une excellente compréhension finale.
Elle a été 6 fois championne du monde de la lecture rapide.
Salut ! Pour ce Master Class' nous allons parler, vous l'avez bien compris, de lecture rapide.
200 mots, 300 mots à la minute c'est en moyenne la vitesse à laquelle on lit.
Du coup je me suis testé y a quelques années pour ça,
et je me suis rendu compte que je lisais au rythme de 310 mots à la minute
avec un taux de compréhension de 47%.
47% c'est pas beaucoup.
Mais en fait c'est la moyenne.
C'est là où j'ai compris qu'on pouvait améliorer ça,
et y a carrément des concours de ça,
y a des méthodes pour lire plus rapidement,
et c'est de ça dont on va parler aujourd'hui !
Notre première erreur quand on lit c'est de lire mot à mot en "subvocalisant".
C'est à dire qu'on se parle intérieurement, on lit mot à mot intérieurement,
on a même des micros mouvements de gorge comme si on était en train de parler,
on se raconte à nous-même ce qu'on lit.
C'est une grosse perte de temps et une grosse perte de compréhension au final.
L'idée principale de la lecture rapide c'est de faire moins de mouvements oculaires.
On le lit pas comme ça aussi simplement, on le lit comme ça.
On ne fait que de revenir en arrière en permanence.
Et quasiment tous les 2 mots on fixe le regard pour bien comprendre.
Il faut passer ça.
Déjà pour la lecture rapide il faut se mettre dans un environnement calme et bien éclairé.
Au début quand vous allez essayer d'appliquer les techniques de lecture rapide,
vous allez perdre du temps de lecture,
parce que vous allez plus penser à appliquer les méthodes qu'à lire.
Ça c'est tout à fait normal, c'est une étape indispensable
entre le fait d'appliquer des méthodes en y pensant et le fait d'appliquer des méthodes naturellement.
Une bonne chose à faire qui prend pas trop de temps c'est au lieu de s'arrêter tous les 2 mots,
essayer de se forcer à ne fixer le regard que tous les 4-5 mots environ.
Mais surtout, en quelques minutes vous pouvez augmenter par 1,5, voire par 2,
votre rythme de lecture et votre rythme de compréhension.
Puisque plus on lit vite, mieux on comprend car plus on synthétise.
Ça paraît très étrange dit comme ça mais c'est la réalité.
Tout d'abord, contrairement à ça qu'on nous a appris à l'école, ce qu'on nous a répété,
"C'est pas bien de lire avec son doigt" c'est pas vrai.
Lisez avec votre doigt, ou avec un petit marque-page.
Il vous faut un guide de lecture. C'est ce qui va éviter aux yeux
d'aller un petit peu au-dessus, un petit peu en-dessous, de perdre votre regard.
Le guide, c'est le plus fonctionnel pour ça.
Et en plus vous allez vous donner vous-même le rythme avec votre doigt
en le déplaçant de plus en plus rapidement.
Vous pouvez essayer de lire comme ça durant 5-10 minutes pour vous réhabituer.
Une fois que vous avez fait ça vous allez franchir une autre étape.
Chaque page que vous allez commencer à lire, ou les paragraphes que vous allez commencer à lire,
vous les lisez à partir du 4ème mot.
Ne vous embêtez pas avec les premiers,
et vous allez voir que vous allez les photographier et les comprendre sans les avoir lus ni subvocalisés.
Et de la même manière, arrêtez-vous au milieu de la dernière ligne de la page ou du paragraphe.
Votre cerveau l'a photographié, il l'enregistre et il le comprend.
Appliquez cette nouvelle technique à la première (technique) durant encore 10 minutes,
et au bout de ces 10 minutes là,
donc ça fait 20 minutes que vous avez déjà amélioré votre temps de lecture,
efforcez-vous à ne fixer le regard que 2 fois par ligne maximum.
Alors que la plupart du temps vous vous arrêtez 7, 8 voire 10 fois.
Et déjà en appliquant ces 3 méthodes là, ces 3 simples méthodes,
et en vous efforçant de le faire maintenant à chaque fois,
vous allez améliorer votre temps.
Pour aller encore plus loin dans ce Master Class'
je vous propose trois choses. Il y a un site que j'utilise qui
s'appelle Zap, Zapreader c'est
un site gratuit, il n'y a pas trop de pub ça va...
il n'y a pas besoin de s'inscrire. Vous copiez coller le texte
que vous voulez lire là dedans. Ça peut être un mail,
ça peut être un article sur internet, peu importe...Vous définissez
votre vitesse de lecture idéale et
il va vous l'envoyer, vous le faire tourner en mode lecture rapide.
Ça va entrainer votre oeil et surtout,
vous allez vous surprendre quand vous allez voir à quel point vous
lisez rapidement et vous comprenez bien ce qui se dit.
Je vous mets évidemment le lien dans le descriptif.
Je vous mets aussi un autre lien vers un
autre site qui est sur mes exams.com.
C'est pareil, il n'y a pas besoin de s'inscrire, il n'y a pas trop de pub.
C'est simplement un test pour définir aujourd'hui votre
vitesse de lecture et votre taux de compréhension.
J'ai essayé ce test, c'est pas le meilleur qui existe non plus,
mais il a l'avantage d'être gratuit.
Et enfin pour moi la bible à ce sujet je vous en ai
déjà parlé dans une vidéo, c'est
Tony Buzan avec son livre sur la lecture rapide,
je vous mets le lien aussi dans le descriptif.
Si vraiment, vraiment, vraiment, vous vous
intéressez et que vous voulez aller jusqu'à
mille mots à la minute, c'est à dire
250 pages en une heure environ,
avec une vraie bonne compréhension, je vous recommande ce bouquin là.
S'il y a une médiathèque près de chez vous
peut-être qu'ils l'ont, si quelqu'un l'a, faites
le vous prêter, c'est pas de l'incitation à l'acheter,
mais de l'incitation à vous le procurer et à le lire.
Je vous mets le lien, comme ça
vous aurez toutes les références. J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu!
Je vous assure que la lecture rapide c'est
passionnant si vous vous y mettez un petit peu, au moins
les trois points que je vous ai donné tout à l'heure.
Essayez de le faire. Merci en tout cas d'avoir regardé ! Si ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir, en laissant un petit
mais..rapide POUCE EN L'AIR!
N'hésitez pas à laisser un petit commentaire puisque évidement je les lis
tous et ça m'intéresse à chaque fois
vous me donnez des idées, n'hésitez pas à les mettre vos idées aussi
pour lire plus vite, ou d'autres Master Class'
que vous voulez ! Partagez aussi cette vidéo si vous pensez
que ça peut intéresser d'autres personnes et
ABONNEZ VOUS À LA CHAÎNE puisque mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an ! Donc rendez-vous demain à 11H !
Ciao !